What is the purpose
of the corporation?
This is one of the
most controversial
and perhaps one of the
most important questions
that we need to
address in this course
and that you will need to
address as the next generation
workforce leaders.
Why is this the case?
Well, because American
CEOs have answered
this in two different ways.
From the 1940s through the '70s
and '80s and into the 1990s,
there was a broad view of
the corporation that has now
narrowed down to focus
on maximizing shareholder
value in the short run.
Here's a quote from the CEO
of Sonesta Hotels, Roger
Sonnabend.
He says, "Social responsibility
and expanding profitability
are not at odds
with one another.
Quite the contrary.
They are two faces
of the same coin."
That view was shared by a
lot of CEOs of his era--
best illustrated
perhaps by graduates
of this important institution
called the Harvard Business
School.
The class of 1949 is known for
producing an enormous number
of CEOs that spread across the
economy over the next decade
or two.
Many of them had been
veterans of World War II.
In fact, 90% went to the Harvard
Business School on the GI Bill.
Many of them were
first-time college students
in their families.
Many of them grew up
during the Depression,
and they were imprinted by
the hardships of that time
as well as a commitment
to community service
that was embedded in
them during World War II.
So they had a particular
view of their responsibility.
Let's start with an example from
one of the best-known companies
of the 1950s through the '80s.
Xerox-- one of the
companies that was a pioneer
high-technology company--
lead in the development
of office products.
And it was led, from 1968 to
1982, by Peter McColough--
one of those graduates of
Harvard Business School,
class of 1949.
Peter McColough graduated
and went to work at Xerox,
worked his way up through
various managerial capacities,
became CEO in 1968.
Xerox was located in
Rochester, New York, where
they had manufacturing
operations,
and McColough
believed very strongly
that the role of the CEO was
to be a good corporate citizen
in the community.
He worked very hard
to improve education,
to build strong community
colleges, which then provided
a very competent workforce
for his organization
and for others in the region.
He worked on local
and national politics.
He worked closely
with the labor union
that represented
the manufacturing
employees at Xerox.
They were among the first
to develop, for example,
quality-of-working-life programs
and quality circle improvements
to improve productivity
and to compete with growing
international competition
in the 1970s and 1980s.
And in particular, he
believed very strongly
at developing talent from
within the organization
and particularly led the
way for developing talent
among women and among
minorities within Xerox.
So it's not an accident
that, in 2002, Anne
became the CEO of Xerox--
one of the first women
to rise to that level of
authority in American industry.
And it's not surprising then,
in 2012, that when Anne retired,
the first African American
CEO of a very large Fortune
100 company--
Ursula Burns-- succeeded her.
And the culture carried forward.
The same view of corporate
social responsibility
can be seen in the
words of these CEOs
as was the case with
Peter McColough.
So if you look on Xerox's
Social Responsibility Report
on the web, you'll
find currently
the same words that mirror
what McColough stood for.
Quote, "Since our
earliest days, Xerox's
has embarked on a
neverending journey
to demonstrate that good
business and good citizenship
are not only compatible
but are synergistic."
The report then goes on to talk
about customer satisfaction,
innovation via patents,
community participation,
avoidance of workforce
injuries, and so on,
employee participation
in community affairs, all
as part of what they believe
are the responsibilities
of the modern corporation.
This was the dominant
view, not only of Xerox,
during this time, but also
of other corporations--
best-illustrated by the
statements of the Business
Roundtable, the largest
corporate association
of executives from
the 200 largest
companies in the United States.
And as late as 1990,
the Business Roundtable
made the following
public statement:
"Corporations are chartered
to serve their shareholders
and society as a whole.
The interests of
shareholders are primarily
measured, of course, by
economic returns over time.
The other stakeholders
in the corporation
are its employees, its
customers, its suppliers,
its creditors, its communities
where the corporation does
its business and society as
a whole, and all of these
are vital to the long-term
economic performance
of the corporation."
That's the view up until
around the mid-1990s.
By this time,
business is convinced
that it should focus
on shareholder value.
And so the Business
Roundtable says, "In our view,
the paramount duty of management
and the board of directors
is to the corporation's
stockholders.
The interests of
other stakeholders
are relevant only as derivative
of the duty to stockholders.
The notion that the
board of directors
must somehow balance all
of these other stakeholder
interests fundamentally
misconstrues
the role of the directors
and the responsibility
of the corporation."
Well, this is a big change.
What caused this change?
Well, it was a
revolution in ideas
about the corporation
that came largely
from the academic
literature of the time.
The leading finance professors
of the time, Fischer Black
and Bob Merton at MIT and
their colleague Myron Scholes
at the University of
Chicago had developed
a formula for better
ways of pricing options--
that is, shareholder stock--
so that you could use stock
options to compensate for CEOs.
Their formula made it easier
to use these processes,
and then colleagues at the
Harvard Business School
published a number
of papers saying
we ought to tie shareholder
value to CEO compensation
through the use
of stock options.
And you saw the role
of stock options grow.
You saw the CEO compensation
grow from what used to be about
a ratio of 30 to 1-- that is,
the CEO earned about 30 times
the average employee
in the firm--
to today, where it's
well over 300 to 1.
Well, what was the
consequence of all of this?
One of the examples
that we could
turn to is another venerable
company, STANLEY Tools--
a company that was
a household term
because every toolbox
in America had
good wrenches and other tools
made by the STANLEY Corporation
in Connecticut.
It was a very
socially-responsible company
until the board of
directors got taken over,
and someone said let's really
focus on shareholder value.
And so a new CEO
was brought in place
and started to lay people off,
not as a last resort because
of economic necessity,
but as a preemptive step
to try to boost
shareholder value.
More and more
companies did that.
And in fact, that led New York
Times reporter Louis Uchitelle
to write a very well-known
book called The Disposable
American basically
chronicling how
American corporations changed
their behavior over time.
Did it really benefit
shareholders all that much?
Well, if you look at the data,
the data show that shareholders
got about the same rate
of return-- about 7%--
in the old stakeholder
era as they
were getting in the
shareholder era.
If you had just forced
some of this restructuring,
in fact, their rate of
return goes down a little bit
from the previous time period.
So we've imposed a lot
of costs on society,
but have we really
benefited the shareholders
as the theory might suggest?
That's a question that
you will have to answer.
The era of maximizing
shareholder value
in the short run
is still with us.
Does this work for the future?
Does it work for
your generation?
That's a question
that you will need
to address as you shape
the work, the workforce,
and the corporation
of the future.